I'm separating out a couple of moments
from yesterday's deranged and delusional
event that Donald Trump did in Florida
where he is just going after Ron
DeSantis or as he knows him wrong run to
sanctimonious not meatball Ron at least
not as far as we know so far this is a
building Civil War
but it is between
a guy who's running for president and a
guy who right now isn't actually running
for president Ron DeSantis hasn't
announced anything but Ron DeSantis even
without announcing is polling so
strongly relative to Trump winning in
some polls losing in others but polling
very strongly for a guy who's not
running that Donald Trump is threatened
Donald Trump's ego is threatened Donald
Trump's a path to Victory is threatened
now I do think at the end of the day
Trump is going to run circles around
DeSantis in a national campaign because
of the Optics I don't think DeSantis is
up for what it will take to defeat Trump
in a national campaign but regardless
Trump is feeling threatened so Trump is
regularly going after Ron DeSantis who
he claims on Truth social all the time
he never thinks about he told us last
week I never think about the guy and yet
he brings him up here is Donald Trump
bringing up the crowd size it's the same
old stuff folks the crowd size that Ron
DeSantis didn't get a big crowd in New
York yesterday and not only does this
mean Trump is thinking about Ron
DeSantis he's also paying attention to
DeSantis events we're there actually
it was really good it was really it dies
and everybody thought it was great and
about two three days later oh there
didn't seem to be much energy they'll
even take this crowd you know Rhonda
sanctimonious had a crowd in Staten
Island for that
139 people and said now we got a lot of
people we have 139 times about 30. the
audio clearly being run by antifa during
this event
we got a lot of people here but I always
say
hit your enemy a little bit early some
people say don't but I say do but you
know yeah so there is Trump hitting the
enemy early as he says that which is a
completely deranged language to be using
in these circumstances against the guy
who hasn't even announced that he's
running and then in another moment
during this Trump mentioned the um vote
differential between DeSantis for
governor and Trump for president
continuing to try to uh it's basically a
penis size contest well and I never
mentioned this because I don't like
hitting Republicans I really don't right
but I did get 1.2 million more votes
than Ron 1.2 million more wow nobody
wants to mention the Press refuses to
mention it we'll have to talk to our
club 47 people about this
they don't want to mention good thing no
I got 1.2 million votes more than Ron
and Ron did good in Florida but I did
great yeah so basically all the hits at
this event I mean there was almost
nothing missing from Trump's routine
from this weird event okay he didn't do
Obama that's true that that was missing
but short of that really doing all the
old tricks so Trump will be um in East
Palestine Ohio tomorrow I don't know if
there's going to be any kind of live
event if there is we might look at
covering it if Joe Biden visits East
Palestine Ohio we will also cover it and
all of the clips these these thick and
Meaty clips that I played for you today
you can find all of them on our
Instagram by going to Instagram and
searching for David Pacman show did you
know that half of Americans are
deficient in vitamin A vitamin C and
magnesium most Americans are deficient
in vitamin D I take vitamin D during the
winter it is sometimes difficult to eat
exactly the right amount of each food to
get exactly what you need I just make my
life simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens
in the morning one scoop of ag1 I get
the entire day's worth of 75 high
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients it's what I want
it's no more it's no less it's not
making any outlandish claims it's just
an easy sustainable routine I've tried
different ways of taking vitamins ag1 is
cheaper it's quicker it's tastier I'm
not fumbling around with different
capsules it tastes great to drink
straight with water some times I'll put
it in a smoothie or Shake it's simple
it's something easy you can do going
into the new year staying properly
nourished athletic greens is giving my
audience a free year supply of vitamin D
I take that every day in Winter plus
you'll get five free travel packs of ag1
go to athleticgreens.com Pacman the link
is down below